where do you think you and Pat stands in
history in terms of wine Bank you know
I'd be lying if I wouldn't say the best
you know we honestly committed ourselves
to the game so our team to one another
it didn't matter who got the title you
know who was making the call or whatever
it may be if he did it I did if I did he
did it and I think that's what showed
and made us a great fruit to play with
Navarro Bowman retired now from the San
Francisco 49ers Patrick Willis
surprisingly retired a few years ago
Bowman believes the best teammates at
the linebacker position in NFL history
so that's the inspiration for today's
draft we've been taking our ideas from
other sports today we're taking our idea
from football so Chris Sims the best
teammates ever to play at the same
position best at the same position who
were teammates you know what let's go
tails here and it's rigged and this is
what you're excited today right because
you were so bad yesterday and your dad
called you out earlier and he was not
joking around so the pressure is on you
to deliver to death thank you very much
I don't give a damn what you say or what
my dad say so I'm not gonna be forcing
this okay
I'm gonna do one that's a little weird
here right off the bat but rocker I
think it's hard to defend this I'm gonna
say Joe Montana and Steve Young right
off the bat I mean I know they weren't
playing on the field at the same time
but damn you know how many times can we
really look at an NFL roster and go
there was two Hall of Fame quarterbacks
on the same roster at the same time you
know I know it's not like sexy and they
weren't on the field like a Patrick
Willis or Navarro Bowman but regardless
I just I have to look at that the
quarterback position of course is the
marquee position of the sport you have
to have somebody competent and good at
that
at that position to be a successful team
and these two guys were a big part of
why the 49ers were relevant for you know
16 17 years in a row because
whyn't Montana right into Steve Young
and Steve Young took over and they went
to NFC championship games and of course
won a Super Bowl and in 94 so yeah I'm
gonna throw them into the mix here even
though it's kind of against the spirit
of the rule no no I listen to you you're
it you're in the right church but your
butt is planted in the wrong Pew
Christopher Davidson I am stunned and
there was one certain person out there
who may be chugging a beer and or sky
very disappointing I mean look at it I
don't need to cross-examine you on this
I was thinking we could do a little roll
this isn't hard not many steps of logic
in this surely you agree that Brett
Favre was a better quarterback than
Steve Young yeah we agree with and
you've said many times Aaron Rodgers in
your view is the greatest player in the
history of the game yeah I'm not I
didn't how do you not pick Favre and
Rogers just cuz I just felt like you
know the careers not over for Rodgers
yet get worse okay so maybe I made a
mistake there okay he may be calling
back in all right go ahead with round
two you've already lost let's see if you
can dig your way out
that was round that was your pick okay I
like hey you just came out and said that
okay I'm gonna do I don't know which one
to do here you know what you were so
proud of yourself for Montana you're
young and you're so rattled now that you
should have gone far from Rodgers you
don't know what you're gonna do well I
have this like too many options here
with this one but okay I'm gonna go with
one to the I'm gonna go to the 70s all
right I'm gonna go with Swan and
stallworth all right there's one of the
best wide receiver duo's in the history
of the NFL I gotta throw them into the
mix here
I mean Lynn Swann did win a Super Bowl
MVP with some of those unbelievable
catches he had I believe that was what
Super Bowl ten against the Dallas
Cowboys those you know the epic you know
ball bounces in the air he catches it
that way
of course John Stallworth had so many
big moments in Super Bowl 13 and 14
where he made huge plays to help the
Steelers
you know the Cowboys that second time
and of course the big bombs to help beat
the the Rams in Super Bowl 14 so I think
that's one of the I think it's the best
duo at wide receiver in the history of
the sport ultimately and of course that
was a special team that won four Super
Bowls once again right church wrong pew
Christopher I have two questions for you
yes who would you rather have on your
team Randy Moss or Lynn Swann well I
would rather have Randy Moss who would
you rather have on your team Chris
Carter or John Stallworth
oh okay yes it's your right I'd probably
go Chris Carter okay all right Randy
Moss Chris Carter round two all right
all right Phil is not Rio Phil is not
watching Phil Phil Phil will be back in
bed if he's watching this one this is
just a destruction of dismantling but
Chris Carter Randy Moss lest there be
any confusion that's my second round and
these from the get-go they were
incredible when Moss was a rookie
remember he and Carter worked together
they'll said Jake Reed for good measure
they were spectacular now they only
played together for a few years but
those few years they were together
anyone could have been quarterback just
throw the ball up there and Randy Moss
is gonna go get it and Chris Carter's
running wide open because they're so
afraid of getting beat by Randy Moss
what a combination that they had and
it's a shame they never made it to a
Super Bowl that's the only thing that
stallworth and Swann have on yeah that
they made it the Super Bowls and it
wasn't because but it wasn't because the
Swanton stallworth the Steelers won
those Super Bowls it was because of
their defense and because of their
running game at least the first two so
yeah and they won they won Super Bowls
because of what they did in the second
two their legacy is every bit as big as
Carter and Moss they're okay I was still
take I'd still take Carter and Moss over
stallworth and smile I need uper balls
okay that's what I like my groups got
Super Bowls your group doesn't so much
so okay I'm more of the team kind of guy
that's it you're kind of Antonio Brown
you're mr. big chess I'm the team kind
of guy you know that's just the way it
is you show up for late for work every
now and then and do things like that I
don't I guess yeah you shut up for work
well you showed up late once this year
remember I just turned out for TV no not
for TV but it was for
work nonetheless okay gosh this is not
the day to go first I guess because
you're just gonna well what am I gonna
come up with here that you're gonna crap
on once again no no I will only fight
we'll find out okay here you got I'm
going with the best safety duo I think
in the history of the NFL okay
and that's Earl Thomas and kam
chancellor I'm gonna throw them out
there into this mix right here I don't
know if there was ever a time in the
history of the NFL where I could say one
team had the best free safety in
football and the best strong safety in
football in the same secondary in the
prime of the career playing now I think
it's one that's like you know not looked
at that way yet but I think in like
revisionist history 20 years from now
when people talk about the Seattle
Seahawks they're gonna talk about those
two players and go wow they were
difference making type of guys this
Seattle defense and scheme does not
exist without the type of talents that
Earl Thomas and kam chancellor brought
to the table and first kind of thrusted
this scheme onto the scene I mean kam
chancellor a strong saftey who hits like
a linebacker can play in the box but yet
could cover tight ends and you know play
in space like he was a free safety and
then Earl Thomas was a human missile in
the backend I mean the one of the most
explosive safeties ever Bal Hawking
great range will throw his body around
you know one of my favorite phrases it
with Errol Thomas it applies he's got to
rock it up as but as far as that's
concerned so yeah I'm putting them in
that category right now yeah I don't
disagree with that now look I don't know
that they qualify for inclusion on this
list I can't think of a better
combination of safeties yeah at the same
time than Chancellor and Thomas but I'm
not gonna one-up you on this one I'm
gonna one-up Bowman and Willis on this
one yeah if Bowman thinks that he and
Willis were the best two teammates at
linebacker of all time I have to throw
the challenge flag and I have to rewind
to an era before either of those guys
were born in the 70s you talked about
the Steelers on the the two jacks Jack
Ham and Jack Lambert epitomized
defensive football in the 1970s Jack ham
was more quiet you know Lambert
had that intimidating present with the
giant shoulder pads and the missing
teeth and he would knock a kicker down
or no he didn't lock the kicker down it
was it was cliff Harris in Super Bowl 10
that congratulated the kicker right
field goal right
and that was what that's one of the most
memorable moments of any football game
I've ever watched in my life when Jack
Lambert grabs cliff Harris and throws
him to the ground
that's the kind of Intimidator Lambert
was they were the core of that defense
even though the defensive line well
every level of that defense was great
there was something about those
linebackers yeah and Jack ham and Jack
Lambert the best teammate combination at
linebacker in NFL history yeah it's it's
it's hard to argue that one I mean it
certainly is special I they were on my
list as well I didn't want to pick
another Steelers you know combination
there so that's kind of where I backed
off of it but yeah this is a tough one
and you know what my problem is with
some of these times I just go off the
top of my head you know you know I love
football and I got a pretty good
knowledge of history and this is where
yeah I could have maybe researched a
little harder to maybe shut you up a
little bit but wait did you have any
other good ones on there like I also
thought about doing bo Jackson and
Marcus Allen even though they weren't
really great together they were still
two great entities that were playing the
same position on the same team that was
another one that was you out there
Jerry wrote Jerry Rice and Terrell Owens
you know that was another one I thought
about as well but Jerry was so at the
end of his career I just didn't feel
like it counted as much so I didn't want
to go you almost I didn't I didn't even
rhyme II didn't even stand out to me
that they were ever teaming right I was
so late in Rice's career and before
Owens had really established himself
it's like Owens didn't establish himself
until rice goes green yeah he rode to
the very end he broke that single-season
you know the single game catch record
and Jerry Rice's last game as a 49er
that was kind of like the hey here's
Terrell Owens he's the new guy in town
but well who else did you have on your
list you have anybody else there I had I
had Dan Hampton and Richard dent
even though Hampton was defensive tackle
I know it's kind of iffy about those
guys yeah yeah yeah if we'd have gone to
another round that would have been my
next one but I'll rest with my three
rounds
and I'm a little nervous today because
you you were you were very very anxious
to do this draft you wanted to do it
yesterday and you're ready to do today I
I had assumed you would actually
gathered your thoughts but know you've
been hoisted on your own petard once
again you've got Montana and young
whereas I had Favre and Rogers you have
stallworth and Swann whereas I have
Carter and moss you went with our old
Thomas and kam chancellor I went with
the two greatest linebackers teammates
of all time Jack Cam and Jack Lambert
that's our draft for today
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports